welcome everybody few things I wanted to
get to this week I didn't have the
chance and now I do so let's do it
there's a quaint little hypothesis from
my pillow CEO and founder Mike Lindell
about the forthcoming election and as
many of you know Mike pillow as we know
him or even just pillow for short he is
determined to grind to us to a
screeching halt the 2022 and 2024
elections and his new idea is something
about voting machines and he's
explaining it to Steve Bannon and it's
the blind leading the blind and I can't
tell whether Bannon believed this this
stuff or whether either of them do but
take a look at the new strategy
this is wild this live link up with
these tech technology people that you
can actually go and get it to individual
states and get injunctions to basically
shut down the machines to be used in the
2020 midterm elections and state
elections
yeah the 2022 that's correct Steve and
in any elections it would be over uh
we're gonna get it is over Seminary
injunctions and it's with no machines
because they cannot do elections
accurately and they can and they can be
manipulated it wouldn't be accurate 100
they said they did it they're caught now
they're guilty it's in violation of fun
of fundamental rights to vote under
42-usc 1983 a violation of equal
protection and also due process we are
starting with seven states immediately
um we're going we're going we're going
to get to every state and uh every of
course you're going to get pushed back
and stuff but every state ever the
people this by the way you know who the
stand who has the standing all the
voters Steve yeah so this there's a
funny aspect to this and
pillow is obsessed with machines and
he's trying to remember when he said he
was going to sue every machine we're
doing a class action lawsuit against all
machines
that is one of the funniest clips my
espresso machine has gone into hiding
because of this forthcoming lawsuit it
is absolutely horrified it may be
completely shut down the funny thing
about this is It's cartoonish it's it's
off the wall it's kooky it's it's all
these different things
but the precedent that or the the rules
the law that pillow cites just doesn't
have anything to do with the use of
voting machines when he talks about 42
U.S code 1983 that's a section called
civil action for deprivation of Rights
and when you read it it says every
person
um and anyone who is deprived of a right
has the ability to seek recourses and
you know gives you standing
the fact that voting machines are used
doesn't deprive anyone of Rights you
would have to demonstrate that and of
course pillow and others have failed to
demonstrate that the mere existence of
voting machines deprive someone of the
right to vote which is the the right
that we're talking about here in
addition to this
um there's kind of the other side of it
which is if you got rid of all machines
if you if you did that and we simply had
Universal vote by mail everybody mails
in a paper ballot and it's paper ballots
counted one by one and then recounted
you you count them and then you recount
them okay
I would be fine with that and it
wouldn't be particularly good for
Republicans
um they love to claim oh the left would
would use mail-in ballots for fraud and
all of it there's no evidence of that
and we saw that in 2020 they claimed it
but there was not actually any evidence
of it it would take a really long time
and we've gotten used to well we want
results sooner than that
but I would be fine with universal vote
by mail and count every ballot by hand
and have a paper trail I I'm okay with
that and I think many on the left would
be the reason they are trying to mess
with the machines so to speak is uh both
self-serving and due to things they
misunderstand as as is often the case
with much of what uh Republicans do so
does pillow believe this that he's about
to shut down all these elections because
they're getting rid of all the machines
does Steve Bannon it's hard to believe
that anyone would believe it at the same
time they've been saying it for a year
and a half so I don't know you be the
judge if you're like me you love
documentaries and you should really
check out our sponsor curiositystream
the only streaming service dedicated to
documentaries curiosity stream has a
better selection of documentaries than
Netflix Hulu and Amazon they always have
the newest and most critically acclaimed
titles including a bunch of stuff I
can't find anywhere else I just finished
watching fiddling it's about Bluegrass I
know so little about bluegrass it's
pretty fascinating and I watched a
documentary about it fiddlin I've been
using curiosity stream for over a year I
always have it going on my TV in the
evenings you really can't run out of the
amazing content constantly adding new
stuff if you want a deep dive into a
thought-provoking new topic they have
documentaries if you just want to unwind
and turn your brain off they have
documentaries there as well right now
curiosity stream is giving my audience
25 off that comes out to just
14.99 a year a year that's just a dollar
25 a month go to
curiositystream.com Pacman the link is
down below